[Aplausos]
o que vocês sentiram quando viram o mar
pela primeira vez a sua imensidão a sua
força a sua placidez a sua coroa azul
límpido da cinza escuro verde jade
branco pela força dos ventos
indomável sem nenhum controle batendo
fortemente nas ondas nas pedras nas
areias e foi nesse ambiente que eu
descobrir a grande
a grande importância da flexibilidade
essa foto foi tirada há cinco anos atrás
uma semana antes do acidente e foi nesse
palco na baía de guanabara que eu tive
contato com o mundo com a sua força da
flexibilidade que desenhou toda a minha
história de vida começou aos 12 anos de
idade teve uma oportunidade única de ter
bico em um pequeno barco de madeira com
vários amigos e tudo começou como uma
brincadeira uma brincadeira de criança
de jovens que com seus barcos velhos
todos remendadas e aparafusados e mani
corados com lixo e tinta que começamos a
desvendar os mistérios do mar e dos seus
elementos e isso foi levando foi de foi
foi a abr o chamdo uma vontade de
competir uma vontade de se aprimorar
de todos esses jovens mas à medida que
foi passando
esse sentimento de competição e
sentimento de querer fazer mais e melhor
foi me desafiando e tinha a limitação do
dinheiro mas por sorte surgiu um barco
que era que vocês devem conhecer que o
competidor estava no olympiacos com ele
o laser e era um barco muito caro ainda
é um barco muito caro e naquela época a
minha família vendo aquele meu aquela
minha vontade de vencer de buscar o meu
sonho se cotizaram pra poder ter acesso
a isso ea partir daí eu comecei a buscar
o meu sonho
treinava treinava busca fazer até
manobras repetidas milhares de vezes
viajei o brasil de tudo que vocês possam
imaginar para poder estar nesse ambiente
de competição
lidei com todo tipo de gente
e finalmente eu consegui ser campeão
brasileiro duas vezes mas essa atividade
me trouxe o que é mais importante pra
mim que foi o mundo da competição
foi quando eu comecei a correr as
regatas e é o momento em que você tem
que observar toda a diversidade que você
está envolvido porque eu velejar
você precisa conhecer sentindo rosto
a força do vento
você consegue perceber a a mudança de
temperatura na água
você consegue percebia a diferença de
maré
as pequenas oscilações que o vento é
capaz de trazer para você tomar sua
decisão
e dessa maneira é que você consegue
perceber as manobras que você tem que
fazer
e eu quero falar de sonho
quando você tem uma vontade é muito mais
do que uma meta um objetivo o sonho é
uma marca que você quer ao isso
absurdamente chegar lá
esse sonho que me move um dia de puder
poder usar essa mão pra ler voltar e
poder manusear um ipad ou manusear um
livro eu tenho encontrado as pessoas
muito dentro das caixas presas em visões
históricas presa em visões próprias se
limitando ao seu modo de ver seu modo de
enxergar vendo ao mundo a sua maneira
e essa visão dentro da caixa sem nenhuma
flexibilidade é que formou as nossas
guerras que destrói empresas destrói
casamentos destrói famílias e destrói as
sociedades e destrói pessoas e debaixo e
à sua volta
tem tanta coisa escondida tanta coisa
pra informar pra você ea inflexibilidade
a falta de pontualidade te deixa numa
caixa presa sem poder ver o que está em
volta e fazer uma escolha melhor
agora vamos lá vão aprender a ciência
tem mostrado a capacidade do cérebro de
comandar um corpo humano de forma
involuntária com uma perfeição
fantástica e de se transformar e de
forma absolutamente magnífica ele é
capaz de ter uma nova
a plasticidade à medida em que ele toma
um acidente um acidente qualquer que
seja ele se transforma
ele se adapta à nova situação e por que
não aprender com ele e por que não fazer
igual a ele porque a única diferença que
está sob o nosso controle o comando
dessa maravilhosa peça que é o cérebro
agora não basta ser flexível não basta
aprender com a pluralidade tem que ser
otimista
o otimismo é uma cl é uma é uma atitude
absolutamente necessária é importante
pra que você atinge os seus sonhos
o otimismo é que faz pessoas que não têm
que fizeram coisas impossíveis fazer
coisas se tornaram impossíveis eu quero
então fechar dizendo o seguinte pra
vocês
a mudança é a regra sempre foi mais do
que nunca é importante
flexibilidade para sair da caixa e criar
algo novo pra criar novos horizontes
sonha não pare de sonhar porque essa foi
a esse foco é que vai trazer tudo de
todas as energias que você precisa para
chegar aonde você quer do jeito que você
quer e muito otimismo porque o otimismo
é que te faz acordar todo dia para
buscar o seu sonho
obrigado
[Aplausos]